[Musique]
si durant cette crise sanitaire sans
précédent les dons et les efforts se
multiplient pour tenter de soutenir les
hôpitaux et les soignants la guerre
médical pour tenter d'endiguer ce virus
le plus efficacement possible à un coût
et pas n'importe lequel pour la première
fois de son histoire la sécurité sociale
devraient connaître un déficit record
qui avoisinerait les 41 milliards
d'euros à titre d'exemple la sécurité
sociale était en 2019 presque à
l'équilibré avec seulement 1,9 milliard
d'euros de déficit c'est donc un bond
spectaculaire que connaît aujourd'hui le
service de santé public et pas seulement
à cause des hospitalisations si le fait
que les malades se multiplient sur le
sol français est une des raisons de
cette augmentation du déficit la part la
plus importante de ces pertes est
directement liée à la baisse de
l'activité économique du pays
en effet la sécurité sociale est en
grande majorité financées par les
cotisations sociales et la csg qui avec
le pays à l'arrêt ne peuvent plus être
collecté une amputation de budget qui
avoisinerait les 20 milliards d'euros
une crise jamais vue depuis la première
guerre mondiale sauf qu'à l'époque la
moyenne d'âge des français était plus
jeune et la france a connu les trente
glorieuses période faste qui lui a
permis de se relever probablement plus
facilement qu'il le sera possible
aujourd'hui face à cette importante
dette chacun cherche des solutions est
une question se pose maintenant faut-il
suspendre la sécu aux plus aisés
[Musique]
alors faut-il suspendre la sécurité
sociale aux plus aisés alors je vais
donner la parole d'abord j'ai envie de
donner la parole à valérie bénaïm et
après je vous le dis je donnerai tout de
suite la parole aux forcenés
le forcené qui a pris des notes le
forcené qui est colère le forcené qui a
le front qui brille on dirait qu'il a
mis du cirage sur son fronton matelas
produirait une boule de pétanque
allez c'est parti valérie m'a dit ma
chérie chômage alors je pense qu'il ne
faut pas supprimer enfin voila il l'aide
y compris aux personnes et vous étiez
puisque le principe même des cotisations
quand on paye nos impôts
c'est au prorata de ce trio gagnant donc
voilà beaucoup
donc il ya une harpie de l'application
être les conséquences par rapport à ce
que l'on y donne est donc évidemment ce
moment là sinon les plus riches au monde
eh ben je suis désolé je ne paye plus
mes impôts puisque de toute façon je
n'ai plus accès à la sécurité sociale
donc ce serait un enfer avec bonne
attention il ne faut pas très bien alors
oui gilles verdez il faut absolument pas
parce que le principe de la sécurité
sociale c'est l'universalité
c'est à dire que tout le monde paye pour
tout le monde et fethi mention dans les
villes est plus riche on va se retrouver
sur un système à l'américaine où les
plus riches vont avoir leur sécurité
sociale leur santé privés et les plus
pauvres n'auront plus rien c'est de ne
jamais jamais et vous le ferez vous
aurez la parole maintenant 10 mai
forcerait à paroles surtout ne pas
supprimer cette sécurité sociale c'est
le système le plus juste
alors le forcené alors je vois expliqué
très clairement ce que je pense
concernant le projet de la sécurité
sociale aujourd'hui fait qui vend tout
le monde cotise à la sécurité sociale
et tout le monde effectivement dès le
premier euro dépensé est remboursé ça
c'est le cas actuel on est d'accord avec
ça ou pas christophe nains quand on a un
revenu qui est qui qui qui est faible
effectivement les traits à redon d'être
remboursés à 100% ça c'est la base
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui habite gagne
bien sa vie moi je pense qu'il doit
avoir une franchise et ne pas être
remboursés tant qu'il n'a pas dépensé
jeudi apporte de quoi 250 euros parce
que lui 2 50 euros pour lui si on laisse
il les a pas c'est pas un drame alors
que pour d'autres c'est un drame
d'autre part ils sont que les démarches
minutes est-ce qu'on peut on fait juste
un petit point jusqu'à présent tout le
monde a compris la ce qu'il vient de
dire
c'est faux en quoi c'est faux alors
alors si lui n'en attendez attendez pas
ce qu'est ce qu'il peut nous ré
expliquer de renseigner parce que là il
ya la rumeur déjà qu'ils n'ont pas
compris le forcené s'il vous plaît
restez pas ne demandez rien et risqué
nous votre cheminement qui passe bien
sûr de votre cerveau a directement à vos
yeux mais qui ressort certainement car
quelque part alors au prénom pendant
deux cas le smic prenant deux cas un cas
à un foyer prenons un foyer ouais on ne
voyait 3000 euros 3000 hors du foyer à
3000 euros au nom d'autres foyers dont
le revenu mensuel est deux vinyles euros
ok dans les deux cas la même dépense à
la sécu la même dépense chez le médecin
ok et rembourser de la même façon il
veut même aller plus loin
le slogan non le foyer le faut comment
ça non alors je dis pas pourquoi nous
allons y aller les bactéries c'est alors
allez-y l'aura vu pourquoi non forcené
pour répondre aux besoins de colorants
soyez était porte parole des
républicains elle connaît un petit peu
mieux
[Musique]
quoique non quoique non non merci alors
déjà tout le monde sait qu'on n'est pas
remboursé à 100 bon nous sans les nommer
j'espère vous n'avez vie j'ai passé déjà
qu'il est bon pour massy ou chez le
médecin et déjà il n'est pas remboursé à
100%
il ya déjà des mutuelles qui pensent et
selon les moyens de chacun les médias
sont plus ou moins importantes comme tu
cotises en proportion de ses revenus si
tu daignes 100 euros tu cotises une
certaine somme quittant gagne 1000 du
quotidien peu plus donc déjà tu fais
déjà ton geste de solidarité
si tu ne rembourse pas nous allons il ne
cotiseront plus et là c'est la seule des
systèmes non on ne peut pas demander
c'est assurantiel qui ne peut pas
demander à des gens de petit quelque
chose quand ils n'ont pas de preuve
alors laurence mais je sais c'est que je
me serais ce point je vois la tête de
castaldi y voit il a un air triste ou 8
mai se dit je pense que j'ai peut-être
dit une connerie jean-michel 2d comme
journaliste au figaro
est-ce que vous pouvez parler aux
forcenés si vous faites pas les yeux qui
se ferme de plus en plus et la gueule
de plus je crains malheureusement que
ben jama et pris des cours de les cours
d'économie auprès des candidats de loft
story et secret story ça lui a pas porté
chance malheureusement système sécurité
sociale que le monde entier nous envie
et le seul à le dénigrer alors que tous
les autres aimeraient bien le système de
dire de la france
mais si je dois tu veux casser un
système peu tout le monde ne veut pas le
cas c'est tout le monde consulte en
fonction c'est comme c'est aussi con que
si moi je disais moi j'ai la chance que
jamais être malade
c'est comme si je disais je ne pas
coûter lcq parce que j'en pense même pas
c'est aussi con que je m'arrête
non mais je m'arrête deux petites
secondes n'est jamais malade hier je
vous ai demandé à une tendinite et vous
avez dit que vous étiez malade j'ai la
rage de dents mais j'ai failli
démissionner après 0,6 g presse de
l'upra et y apprend et avant-hier ma
part mais excusez moi et est juste il ya
un mois et après jimmy woha m qui vous
amener des médicaments pour chez vous si
vous étiez malade aussi ah bah oui j'ai
le corona excusez moi adacore non mais
bon voilà
mais donc c'est bien de nos coûts donc
vous êtes malade quand même voilà on en
voit oui mais je pars en jeu bois que je
dois dépenser 30 40 euros à la pharmacie
ou artistiques en plus et je jouis c'est
sûr mais on sait en fait pourquoi et on
sait pourquoi vous aller à la pharmacie
vous n'êtes pas pour acheter des
médicaments des chewing gum au collège
l'ambitionne l'air mais alors j'ai eu le
verbe est vrai dire aux forcenés que son
système de franchise qui veut imposer en
france pour une première fois il est
totalement débile parce que la franchise
justement ça va vers la privatisation
que tu instaure le forcené un système de
franchise
ça veut dire que vous mettez des
barrages au delà de telles sommes
certains ne pourront plus accéder mais
donc la revue mais j'en reviens vous
aller vers un système qui vous arrange
vous peut-être parce que vous êtes riche
où vous aurez accès à des fonds qu'il
faut non plus un mais non vous n'avez
pas de maison d'arrêt expliquez vous
alors expliquez vous clairement
désinhibée s'il vous plaît est ce qu'on
peut avoir l'explication du forcené
comprenez on vous aime le fort sinon
vous aime énormément les problèmes qu'on
a
moi j'ai pas excusez moi ce n'est alors
fait un effort on ne comprend pas
comment des gens inscrits se trouve que
1 les plus aisés c'est ce qu'ont pensé
les silhouettes de minutes le forcené
est ce que vous pouvez reprendre votre
théorie depuis le début on repart on
efface tout on n'est pas de conseils à
saillé s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
de minutes peu forcé le forcené deuxième
la sécurité sociale ces parcours alors
culte et moi je veux bien jouer mais
tout ce que vous voulez vous dit juste
une chose
l'effort national doit passer par
l'effort de chacun effectivement pour
certaines personnes ne pas envoyer sa
feuille de sécu
c'est un geste voilà on je ne me fais
pas remboursé parce qu'effectivement je
n'ai pas réellement besoin des 50 euros
ont dû dépenser chez le médecin ou des
60 euros des 100 euros
c'est la base et pour d'autres c'est 50
euros c'est vital c'est primordial
c'est tout ce que je dis c'est tout ce
que je dis à des deux femmes de me
raconter la messe qui est en plus un
genre je rajoute que les plus riches en
plus sont les meilleurs mutuelles sont
remboursés réellement eu à 100% pour les
lunettes pour les dents pour tout le
reste
alors écoutez pourriez vous un peu dans
la vie des gens et après nous parler
mais arrête de dire des conneries aura
plongez vous dans la vie des gens toi
aussi tu es tu étais tout pour attaquer
la vie normale je crois qu'on est plus
plonger dans la vie des gens que toi
bien sûr bien sûr médailles par le
forcené
jamais mon père et sa fille et à
castelnau maintenant c'est quoi ça est
le père de bernadette
je pense qu'on n'a pas les mêmes je
pense qu'on n'a peut-être pas eu les
mêmes chances au départ aujourd'hui que
je dis que tous les riches doivent se
taper dessus mais jeudi la cour sa riche
et longue
ils vont tous se casser j'aimerais aussi
orapi système laurent j'ai bien bossé on
en voit on en voit on envoie notre
meilleur élément valérie b ne même pas
savoir aux séries ce que tu disais tout
à fait valable effectivement à des flux
1 du coup de pelle à titre individuel si
toi effectivement tu estimes que tu peux
te passer du remboursement de 50 euros
ou 2 cents le veau de lait 100 euros ce
que je dis voilà tu le fais à titre
individuel
on avait conscience tu veux le faire de
façon systématique et que ce soit
institutionnalisée tucat serait le
système de la sécurité sociale
et là ce serait dramatique de castella
n'a encore jamais fait on reviendra
demain plus tellement un riche et en pid
de dire écoute moi la feuille de sécu
j'y vais pas je te demande pas ça
pourquoi pas intellectuellement et ben
je dépends la vie de valérie la vie de
jean michel maire donc voyez journée
mangerai judo pendent aux forcenés si
quelqu'un qu'ils aiment l'appeler depuis
hier son bénéfice et ses recettes
miracles puisque visiblement il a des
recettes miracles quelqu'un t'a appris
vraiment moi je dis pas que c'est une
recette miracle
jean michel maire je disais je dis
simplement si aucun d'entre eux vous
comprennent pas ne comprends pas que
l'on rende encore compris ouais je ne
comprend pas ça va te rendras compte
hélas assez bon les meilleurs moi je
suis là je suis moi je vois là je vois
je trouve effectivement alors jusqu'à
forcené 2001 est ce que tu peux nous
plaçant les mots en plaçant les mots
doliprane well as well conscience mais
on y va chaque année chacun chacun a
tragiquement son âme et conscience
reçoit effectivement un salaire ça peut
tout on peut tous être malade évidemment
dans certains cas on a besoin c'est
fondamental d'être remboursé pleinement
et le mieux possible avec effectivement
la sécu avec des complémentaires avec et
cetera les mutuelles pour d'autres et
jordi bien pour ne pas pour l'ensemble
des gens il ya des gens alors c'est pas
la majorité c'est très peu denses 4 5%
6% au père sont françaises et des gens
pour qui l' effort de 2 200 francs de
100 euros ou 200 euros 300 euros
effectivement à la fin du mois c'est pas
un drame ou web et vous trouvez bébé ou
pourquoi pas 400 j'en sais rien 500
réseau libre à lui donner ce qu'il ait
remboursé mais il remboursait de même
façon poursuit qui n'a pas beaucoup
d'argent que lui carey beaucoup c'est
tout ce que j'y vois là je dit pas autre
chose est difficile quand il masque au
nom mais vous d'accord mais si on fait
un effort on fait un effort national ont
fait exprès leurs enseignants quoi mais
non
je vous dis qu'il doit faire un effort
un effort national de faire un geste en
son âme et conscience tiens voilà j'ai
dépassé intrinsèque gorge et à tracer
comment moi je décide de ne pas enlever
la fille de sting parce que je considère
que cet argent là j'en ai pas réellement
besoin et donc je les salue c'est un bon
challenge que je vais vous poser une
question sans rigoler vraiment rien est
ce que quand vous n'envoyez pas votre
fort hood par une voie de fait q vous le
faites en votre âme et conscience
absolument gspair en mon âme et
conscience je me fous de ma gueule à
l'époque et à l'époque j'étais à tf1 je
n'ai au moufia jamais envoyé aucune
feuille de sécu
hawking fait des supers il a considéré
que c'était que c'était mon effort à moi
ils façonnent contribue effectivement à
ne pas agrandir de tous la sécu citant
des ambassades
jean biray gens riches énorme et
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi il n'y a pas
de barreaux aux fenêtres derrière
benjamin s'échapper mais s'échapper la
sofico son avion n'a pas entendu sophie
là-dessus la bonne un bébé ce que
j'écoute j'écoute marge à main
attentivement de ploemeur et on fait
avec
oui et je commence en fait à entendre ce
qu'ils essayent de noir depuis 48 euros
effectivement voilà j'ai compris que ça
avait en fait une espèce de dames
sacrificielle c'est ça c'est à dire que
tu te dis finalement je suis plus aisé
que les autres donc je l'aimé tout
sacrifier mon remboursement de
s'accumuler c'était normal j'ai pas
autre chose tout le monde continue à
cotiser mais certains ne renvoient pas
leurs feuilles c'est ça absolument eh
ben on est en situation de crise et on
situation dit je pense qu'effectivement
les tailles on en prend des mesures qui
fera toute façon payer la note vu pense
qu'effectivement ce re sur un temps
donné effectivement c'est à dire voilà
un tel niveau de salaire annuel ou
mensuel
les remboursements sont stoppées pour un
temps et bien on fera en sorte que le
trou ce que j'ai à dire nuls et j'adore
ce que j'adore chez benjamin c'est que
les pauvres il ya une 3000 euros non non
non non je commence que ne commence pas
dire ça j'ai bien vu un robinet mensuels
par foyer commence pas mal
là ça suffit ces conneries aussi s'il
vous plaît arrêtez vous avez déjà qui
déjà qu'ils voient déjà il a les yeux
tout petit déjà comprends pas ce qu'ils
nient c'est pour le pauvre alors j'en
mangerais savoir si forsonney prône
aussi la suppression des taxes sur
l'alcool par exemple parce que j'ai pas
il a l'air très vives
mais le forcené s'il vous plaît vous
prenez en fait une société individuelle
alors votre geste est symbolique comme
ça mais alors ça veut dire qu'après il y
aura pas ma solidarité collective celle
de l'individu qui prime c'est le
contraire du modèle français pouvez vous
la société que c'est que tous étaient
c'est un ensemble d'individus alors
franchement tu dis n'importe quoi une
fois de plus t'as rien compris
le blairer castaldi catane et si tu paie
le prix t'as rien compris car ce jeune
qui veut réagir encore avant qu'on voit
la vie les téléspectateurs eux
s'il vous plaît je pense qu'on s'est
assez amusé que benjamin même ceux qui
n'ont pas dit si dit pas que des
conneries dit pas que des conneries
après n'en avoir l'avis des
téléspectateurs
alors on va voir l'habilité spectateurs
doit-on suspendre la sécurité sociale
pour les plus aisés
oui à 43% non à 57 %
voilà et mais bon et c'est à ces énoncés
mi-journée il s'en tire bien
non mais c'est non mais c'est pas ça
parce que sinon moi je peux comprendre
certaines personnes qui dit ça et je
peux comprendre ce que dit benjamin à la
limite mais c'est vrai que nous notre
kif c'est d'entendre parler benjamin
castaldi parce que la ville se
comprendra bien c'est juste qu'on se
paie un petit kit perso